[Music]
in peru common baby iris data logic al
sites arthur brown of the country local
communities villages town team live in
the most traditional wave
we are now in the
archaeological sanctuary of pachacamac the
most important sanctuary of the prehispanic peruvian coast
in a sanctuary of
pachacamac is  so big we have serious
problems conserving the
pachacamac site it's just arqueològic outside
south of lima a brown y we had free
million people living in south downs y
monos del sector sublima o west end in
one nation jumping to the side
that I think is the question  what we have
to solve how we make
this site also mean
an important site for the community win it to
engage with them and interactive deming
weixin whitfield from this is it is not
safe acting foundem parties a dyn to the
lives
in pachacamac we had five years ago
back about the last big
invasion were the helicopters and the
mounted police really push  With
all these people, thousands of people
occupied the pampa and the police were able
to push through this invasion and from there
we said that working with the community is
essential for them to help us and
for this not to happen again local
communities can be the first  line of
defense geological poetess the six
won hits of habitats paris by
pernía develop here is from candy camp
partners of income power
[Music]
so to solve part of these
problems we have of invasion on the
site we have an important program with
the community and a  also
educational program and we have educational programs
throughout the school year
spirit stanford sustainable predilection
start of this initiative starlight with
archeology interested in developing
fermín this project against habits
peru
the side this moment
we are the sample of genotype living
cost peru en  pachacamac the ladies of
this association have formed a company
that allows them to invest  working to
protect the site and also allowing them to
improve their quality of life
means that they have empowered
themselves they know who they are and
how important the museum and the site are
to their own lives it
has truly been a dream for me to be
so close  and now participating in this
group because
we have grown personally and economically means that
they have appropriated the iconography
of what is on the walls of what
is in ceramics to produce
handicrafts with identity,
that is, the entire population is
aware of  the importance of this
culture of not invading these places
we already give it more importance that we have to
value and respect our history
I think that one of the satisfactions
for my work is knowing that
we are no longer going to need the intervention of the
police in protection  of the site
[Music]
the researchers, the archaeologists and
the surrounding community who are going to
protect the Pachacámac sanctuary
[Music]